[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to thip ourselves into some glorious
Reaction Time joined with Andrew Flash
Gordon today to deliver on the thing
that we promised we would do months ago
because frankly um I probably wouldn't
be able to get around to this game to
sit down properly and I'm a slow player
like it it'll take me like at least 45
hours to beat the game and I wouldn't be
able to get to that till like November
Andrew you got your copy waiting for you
already at the UPS Store I got mine in
the mail uh in uh coming Sunday but you
should bring it by I will bring it by
well so we can show the evidence yeah
cuz you got a special you got the
special collector it's the collector's
one with Venom and Peter and Miles
attacking him this going to be an
interesting experience because we're
just going to be doing the cut scenes
where they have necessary gameplay
footage because as you know like there's
some gameplay scenes that have story
elements that are necessary to
experience it I've played the first game
played the Miles Morales one I've never
actually watched just
cutcenes before I've never done that
like even on my personal time so it's
going to be very brand new for me yeah I
actually did not originally play the DLC
city that never sleeps so I watched that
originally then I got to play it when I
had the PS5 version remastered version
well I'm excited to deliver our
reactions to you guys so please go ahead
thp that like button subscribe click the
notification Bell because this is
probably going to be divided up into I
think five parts if my math is correct
right now let's see what this is all
about guys I'm excited let's watch
it hey Pete I'm working on a college
application and it says I got to tell
them about myself oh my God this is
happening that's the worst you got any
advice well take me hi I'm Peter Parker
I'm 25 years old I have a bachelor's
degree in biophysics and I'm in love
with the greatest woman ever none of
this seems familiar to me I'm just the
best journalist in this city word
go MJ I try to live up to the example
set by the other greatest woman ever my
Aunt May humble brag
again and a while back I was bitten by a
radioactive spider and got superpowers I
can't put that in my essay hey I'm Ling
the track as I drive the
train what a great way to do a recap
yeah and stop a lot of people who wanted
to hurt it like my mentor Dr Otto
Octavius his lab got shut down by an old
colleague Norman Osborne do you think
Otto's going to come back in this one
wouldn't be surprised it's definitely
open-ended not without great cost I
stopped watching after we did that first
one but I'm no Peter Parker exactly
you're Miles Morales you're 17 years old
and a student at Brooklyn Visions
Academy what else I guess I help out
with my mom's working Harlem every now
and
then she's councilwoman real oh she got
elected did get yeah there is a girl I
like who's spectacular Haley and I think
is one of the best artists in the
city and I also got bitten by a
radioactive spider that gave me
superpowers I learned how to be a
Spider-Man from the
OG well put but I learned how to be a
hero from my dad Jefferson he was killed
by Martin Lee in the city hall
bombing the good I try to do every day
is the good my dad planted in me just
never give up but it's been hard even
with superpowers sometimes we can't save
the people we love no matter how hard we
try a hero is someone who doesn't give
up though they didn't show them Finn I
don't know man I can't talk about me
without talking about
Spider-Man sure you can you just have
to uh you have to lie it's part of being
Spider-Man start another
draft let us continue it's cool it's a
sequel of both games this is
interesting where do we press X I hope
this is just the next hour just this is
me trying to find the charger for my PS5
controller right it's going to be
interesting too when Peter meets up with
Harry curious to see how that goes
down Dr Kurt
Connor oh this is right before he goes
to Europe God damn K Conor looks like uh
Killian Murphy be
ready are you
good promise me
something
anything if this doesn't
work take me
out okay it'll work I like how was in
green yeah yeah little foreshadowing
time
left I want a chance to say
goodbye I'm not going to lose you holds
on to him for selfish reasoning yeah
it's the dichotomy between him and Peter
let you go oh
whoa that was a crazy trans position
that was insane is that how we really
transferred it to him I think that he
was having a dream as my guess or okay
or a flashback then
transition Cool
D Empire State University Peter's Alam
Mater nice we have a bell that's why
you're here keep it up take your seats
I'll
try oh that's so cool him and Haley ins
school and class I'm
here oh he's a teaching assistant good
morning class oh that's cool we have a
new teacher joining us oh teacher on
teacher oh does he have time to do this
maybe it's his new job my name's Pete Mr
Mr Parker he's so awkward and we are all
very lucky today cuz this is physics
class and physics is
awesome
ever wonder how some insects and uh
birds reptiles can just run right across
s he's talking birds like vulture
reptiles like Liz
bathroom
okay is that same just it must be
surface tension is all about
cohesion now in equation form surface
tension gamma think Peter would notice
the sand pouring in have
Aid how's he supposed to get out of
class when he needs to leave can anybody
uh
I I I need your help wow it hasn't even
been like 5 minutes of teing Mr Morales
is it uh are you sure this isn't
something you can handle yourself I'm
sure okay class the sign language
interpreter for Haley or five or
whatever oh my God this if the principal
comes back and sees I'm gone I'm going
to get fired I know but you got to see
this music Q
yeah whoa that's
sick Brooklyn Visions yep Marco by today
yeah crappy timing Sandman
fir worth it yeah this is
awesome oh them getting to play
together this is such a great
opening yeah okay the fact that I can't
hold this right now I know right I like
almost was like wait bro I told you to
be on time it's fine I like the symbols
of the spider names different my colle
review with the school counselor oh you
finished your essay haven't started oh
love talking about school talk very
appropriate at this
time you see him using his Venom Powers
right there that's awesome hey guys you
might want to get downtown fast oh they
know swinging through Brooklyn Jameson
have you on the ground for the bugle
still can't believe old Triple J is your
new
boss really loving the new regime oh I
think he uh J Jon Jamon rebot The Daily
Bugle okay years since our last Showdown
according to Witnesses he was running
down Broadway yelling nonsense they say
he seemed angry and paranoid delusional
of course just exploded man hopefully we
can calm him down I've seen people lose
control like this be careful good thing
there too Spider-Man now good luck
thanks MJ might need the new sounds so
exhausted Peter no way they're untested
no way home prototypes but you brought
them right no com wow scope of all that
sand is crazy what's the plan keep him
busy I got an
idea damn oh
crap oh my God damn that scope of that
jeez what scale still angry after all
these years Marco you should try
yoga oh damn they sh whole floor is
glass whoa that was your idea never said
it was a good
one it was supposed to be a noral day
teach physics have awkward conversations
in the teacher Lounge that's crazy they
visually realiz this everything's going
to be okay
wow I mean he's got to dodge and save
people the at the same time think you
can sign for this delivery it's coming
in hot I'm there you see miles right
there yeah I got him I love how they're
working in tandem together and
improvising it's great mini
Marcos mini
Marcos well cuz he's got so much sand he
can replicate himself s down what a way
to bring variety to your gameplay
experience he's not the only one Sandman
just puked out some new friends what the
he can do that apparently need you now I
Wonder If Venom would be able to do this
seems like some type of enhancement
they're going to bring to the game to
make it more a little bit more
variety the principal students have
evacuated their classroom where are
you how are you supposed to do this it's
hilarious something in my
car what was that nothing I'm just wa
iron arms yeah oh my
God amazing love the iron arms it's like
Rage Instant kill get back here and
supervise your students or else oh he's
so fired sound
[Music]
good it's like a Kaiju monster in the
back feels like demonic you that is so
cool Crystal Evans
called man am I getting expelled hey
you're just cutting class I abandoned
students during a city-wide emergency
they're both pretty
bad wow Jesus great camera work yeah the
cinematography why would you beat
him that's we're going to find out soon
it's their first villain your dead
name I know you're angry at me this has
nothing to do with you leave me alone
nothing to do with
you what are you up to right
now but it's going to hurt
first is he going to pour water on him
yeah yeah break the
pipes it's like zombies
yeah punch your way out of there oh oh
nice that almost gave me a Batman
Forever Vibe where Robin takes Batman
out of the sand yeah he's not really the
nostalgic
type how did Peter beat him before miles
was around oh now we're playing as miles
we got to turn it up a notch use your
bio electricity and your camouflage bet
he's not a big fan of electricity then
either yeah
mind
whoa sick
Dam it did a lot of damage felt that all
right got him right where we want
him
excellent
damn what a what a what a neat way to
get some gore in here the water tank on
the mat building should do the trick you
did raise a good point though how did he
beat him without mil before no
idea should have stayed away
oh my God this is like a nightmare don't
think we got him right where we want him
I love this shot I ad I may have spoken
too
soon and he's definitely getting bigger
this almost has like a a horror element
to it a th% a horror element to it
War it's an interesting choice for an
explosive first villain because it's so
big
yeah I just wanted to live normal like
everyone else well you're not off to a
good
start for a guy like
me there is no other
way how's it going Spider-Man almost
there the water Tank's
ours actually it's his is
now hey sorry what I miss he's trying to
eat me oh let's give him a drink instead
jeez I wonder if the people at school
are wondering if uh Peter and Miles have
a unhealthy relationship between student
and
teacher he just took him to the bathroom
and they being gone for hours right well
they saw them leaving together I mean
yeah it's fair point you raised
[Music]
break out the new toys the new to FL
software patch wasn't stable but here
goes nothing they going to fly yeah we
Wings he flies now the web Wings they're
flying but we're not out of this yet
Marco's at Pier 4 Beach what happens if
he gets all that sand this whole level
was just a giant excuse to Showcase all
the new upgrades yeah got to show the
new toys I see him I'm
behind it's interesting because this is
the real world but it feels like a
nightmare sequence yeah it definitely
[Music]
does it's crazy when you think about no
way home and how samam was one of the
villains there's two Spider-Man they
having the hardest time beating him
mares one and
only
any
ideas the ideas are patting
out yeah class is back in session oh
physics now we're never Spider-Man time
to OH ZIP oh okay regulars at that point
thought they were going to do that dude
this city is destroyed right now I was
going to say they've caused or sandman's
caused so much
damage it's like when you put coins on a
corpse
yeah
I did not think we'd start off so
humongo Jesus this is quite the
oh we're
good
no oh my God God
damn oh my goodness I love it cuz it
feels like you're getting something
violent that's not actually that violent
H City you be
F feels like a real Island now yeah I
have sand everywhere
[Music]
everywhere he means like up as bum
curious what the excuse they give when
they come back to
school Marco is going to be okay is it I
haven't been
okay for a long time
if you need help all you have to do is
ask love how after all this he still
feels pity for him we're going to need
help when they come for
you who's
they come for
us
who's there Andrew could be talking
could be talking about Craven could be
talking about many different people
we've gone from two years ago to present
day to now 6 months
ago
Predator where's
Arnold you grow slow in your old age s
what is their weightlifting routine you
will not
share
damn that music is so menacing I've been
in your Shadow for hours but you sense
nothing path give me a
challenge I love the way Craven delivers
that it's as if he's disa point oh yeah
for
sure like you let me down this is just
not a challenge
anyway I asked for an
equal and this is what you
find
sir perhaps a new hunting
ground black cat we got Prowler wraith
tomb Stone s St huh okay vulture we did
see a bus that had vulture on it did you
notice wraith on there too yeah that's
Yuri
wanabi she became Wraith in the
comics cut that out of the v a crap
you're not editing it stays in the
video you know who plays Yuri Watson ABI
Yuri uh lenth's wife yep
Spiderman dose by the way if you guys
haven't seen Ko's interview video you
alone with all you should check that out
it's up here on the channel
man I can't wait to hear the excuses
when he gets back to I don't know how
you do that job when you're Spider-Man
like know it's too freelance
photographer you can do that you have
wiggle room under hours but something
where you had to clock in yeah Pete you
seeing this
[Music]
that's a great tracking
shot is it going to be like that every
time when you switch player to player
it's going to be a tracking shock cuz if
it is I'm loving that that's what I
imagine it'll
be I love the upgraded look on the iron
arms they look fantastic in this game I
mean they look great in the first one
but even more so in this one it seems
like probably after what Auto discovered
he was able to maybe add a little bit
more is down it's cool he's interacting
with gy now yeah they this is his Ned
wait uh I'm going to try a work around
work
fast let's check on that person in the
limo after the events of the second game
I know that Peter can trust him now too
so what the hell I want like two hours
of side
missions Hospital Jon J I didn't know
for sure he'd be in the game oh wow I
mean we're finally getting him well we
saw him a little bit in Miles moral in
the first mission Santa Claus outfit
yeah
yeah all right Mr Jameson let's get you
to the hospital but yeah this is like
really interacting with him you got to
come see who the vipo was I shutter in
anticipation cealing a hydrant then I'm
on my way Mr Jameson it's Spiderman you
with me flying in on your left on your
right on your left what
where am I
[Music]
Spiderman fine you okay help I've been
Abdu what no I I'm helping you man
someone get a photo with this Mass
criminals kidnap beloved
newsman while he's actually being
saved it's all a matter of perspective
did you just knock out again he just
stopped talking stop talking kidnapped
me I did not sent I
I menaces I'm surrounded by
menaces but J Jonah Jameson is not going
anywhere you hear me I'm not going
anywhere wait where am I going where am
I going ever gets old his hatred towards
them Mr Parker where are you uh
principal Evans hi yes this is me Peter
Parker texting haly sorry there was an
emergency and I I'll I'll be there soon
I
promise I better see you in 10 seconds
or oh no um you're breaking up I I like
getting their compounding
stresses I can't believe I just did that
Peter that was a terrible idea to get
that job
man looks like Ned it really does I was
thinking that it right before you said
it Mr Su oh he just left something about
going on vacation
what say what that's incredible Haley
yes you are Haley also while you were
gone I found out that I got the Rand
scholarship are you serious Danny R
Danny Rand I'm the immortal Iron Fist is
that what it it's reference to that's
the r Rand industry yeah cuz we saw the
uh the building in the first game oh man
I can't watch this uh
but I also can't look away principal
Evans yeah guess who decided to show up
today I I know this looks terrible looks
I'm I'm so sorry it's more than looks it
is I know and this is the last thing
that I wanted to happen and it'll never
happen again I enough for this no I look
no more excuses your job is to protect
these he did not to abandon them you're
fired
does get to the point where you're like
might as well just tell people you're
Spider-Man
dude you being Spider-Man must be so
hard keeping a
job but I'm sure that you're going to
figure it out this almost feels like no
way home with the three of them mhm
mhm that's an interesting duality of it
because so many people know miles is uh
Spider-Man
man better Keeping a Secret words
Peter's a lot more isolated in his
identity
yeah worse than getting fired telling
your girlfriend that you got
fired I'm surprised MJ was like yeah you
you should be a school teacher that's a
that's a great job in your line of
work damn the graphics I know we're
swinging through neighborhoods and
MJ on a bike I'm so used to the cities
yeah yeah yeah for sure like getting
Suburban life
too who traffic was awful tan man really
made a mess seems like you're getting
the hang of that
thing well it is convenient in the city
but I'm not convinced I'm a bike person
it's like Toby Maguire on the bike in
the first couple
movies what's wrong
second and third I got fired
sorry you are so excited about this job
I know I had the she look different you
next week we were going to make a potato
powered
helicopter I'm so sorry a little bit
definitely the hair looks the same
though I might be joining you in the
anointment line what Jonah already
cleaning house sort of he's instituting
a radical
meritocracy hey what does that even mean
it means that whoever doesn't write a
front page story in the next week is
fired well that's why chat gbt
exists you're the best reporter they
have seriously she really
is what you got in
there unsold some carar books running
out of storage at my place
kie silver Sable 14
copies nobody wanted to read about
Saria the go is the biggest out all
right she went there for the war
difference there but if I get fired I
don't know what I'll do do you even need
the bugle to do what you want to do I
tried making an impact from the outside
and 14
copies now I I need to change things
from the inside you can't give up so
soon change things from the inside as
they go inside a home I haven't had time
to
clean did he inherit the house back room
I never we never saw where May lived I'm
assuming that's the case though but yeah
I'm gonna I guess cuz there's no way
these two broke ass individuals could
afford a house in New York well I mean
he's able to have that amazing Tech
unless he just buil it oh speed nonagon
that's the game gy created oh
cool I don't know what I'd do without
you right now Andrew only played these
games
once October that's the year the month
this game came out yeah
jeez what's this for May mortgage the
house to keep Beast to flat and now I'm
sinking
damn don't take this out on her now I'm
sinking you got a house just remember
you save someone you save everyone
Pete that's why he needed that job so
bad the out little details with the
Flies dude you have not taken care of
this place to be honest I'd like to take
some time off but you're going to have a
whole lot of time offord to you guys
went on a vacation last game house I
can't I mean I could but I can't it's
about letting go time I can cover the
mortgage no no I can't let you do that
plus you said Jonah might clean house I
won't let him fire me I know o now the
financial stresses of them being a
couple are getting to them I don't
deserve
you
yeah hey so have you thought any more
about moving in we talked cuz I could
use a maid I need to be in the city
close to where the action is but think
of all the romantic dinners we could
have here when was why is he shouting at
her din Fair Point what are you looking
at some pretty cute old photos of you
man I haven't seen these in a
while
was one of my favorite parts of the last
game just seeing all
the why did she take a picture of
that balance what does that mean it
means what you have to learn how to do
in your life
Peter look look who it is
uncle is that the First time seen Ben no
we saw him in the you saw in the picture
in the first
game Peter said miss you size of those
glasses his first cover
photo Spider-Man is he a threat wow
flashback full on flashback this is
awesome Menace definitely a big fat
Menace let me tell you something about
this called superhero he's neither super
nor a hero so what do that out to a
froad an attention seeker it's a bunch
of nonsense what was that
wowza
a
Peter Peter oh I uh I thought thought I
I heard a a rat in the wall so I tried
to punch it hey what's what's wrong it's
nothing I was
just
wow you're lowenthal's ability to like
go younger his voice it's really
good when I was your age I was head of
The Debate Club captain of the soccer
team and second violin in
Orchestra really impressive every year I
wanted a new feather in my
cap but when I tried to add honor rooll
student on top I fell part instead of
being good at a few things I wasn't good
at
anything
so I scaled
back of
us is a
process not a
destination I love that I love that so
much I've never heard that balance is a
process not a
destination I got to get that t
[Music]
attitude come
on I wonder if they'll have this be a
reoccurring Motif throughout the story
of lessons from uh an
may maybe may had a point I can't take
too much on of course she had a point
damn something's got to give you're just
now learning about this maybe he should
learn about responsibility too while
he's raph's moving a couple of inmates
to Raven coft tomorrow for evaluation
they say who no but I'm going to find
out Raven coft might be the first time
we've heard that name in the uh
MJ
Harry who well cuz at the end of Miles
Mor they said let him out now Norman
Harry the reunion
I missed you too knew he they knew he
was sick
though yeah cuz she found the note in
his uh room in the first mhm so how
was
Europe you're lying you tell him you
know I was being treated in isolation
here in the city and I didn't want you
guys to worry about me good job is it
the same thing your mom had it was past
tense we think it's in remission that's
amazing Harry this is I can't can't
believe it you look
great I feel great this is amazing it's
Amazing Spider-Man
2 dinner tomorrow is good world all time
sake I understood that
reference I'm already liking the feel of
this just a little bit
better that's new yeah it's a little
skill she picked up when we were in
Saria that's awesome the little details
I love what no are you kidding you want
to come
inside actually I was hoping you might
have time to go for a ride with me sure
get in the trunk surpris The Frugal
flyer is still on the
road I was thinking does he have a bike
too used
to recapture your childhood memories bik
n i I found it on the Internet it's a
close match though right that's awesome
yeah God be great to have a rich friend
oh yeah that's awesome I'm riding a bike
as Spider-Man pain just for insurance
but I don't even need it I think you
have more energy than I
do he's been uh locked up in a tank for
a while what's been keeping you busy
just substitute teaching oh my God it's
fired Grand Theft Auto now I've also
been tutoring a high school kid
he's special reminds me a little of me
actually lucky kid I never would have
passed honor Cal without your
help hey I read about out your old boss
Dr Octavius that must have been crazy
it's awesome they put all this to life
oh yeah fling out the neighborhood yeah
and it feels so L why didn't you tell me
you were sick I'd have been there in a
shot you wouldn't have liked what you'd
seen the treatment was horrible I was
floating in a tank with a healing agent
I want to know more about that healing
agent a
tank wow experimental stuff that's what
he took away with it just the tank not
the healing agent you missed it on the
most Port aart
Peter is that is that Midtown exactly
the same as it did 10 years ago Midtown
I imagine it
is Dam
thanks come on why'd you bring us here
we both hated High School yeah remember
that time Flash and his buddies cornered
me and broke my laptop we lost that
presentation we the young entrepreneurs
competition we'd worked for months on
that thing and the state meet was the
next morning I had a backup on a you USB
but it was in your locker we called the
school begging to let us in okay they
said no it was after ours we were so
desperate we walked around the entire
school trying every door until we got to
this
one where we going with this wait what
you I remember we had a Jimmy
yet still after 10 years still able to
do it I love
it
this is awesome with these flashbacks
love it Peter you're being a criminal
you're a
menace
Homecoming this really already this game
has that effect of like Toby Spider-Man
2 where you're getting so much more into
the personal life listening to the game
RB show us that rookie of the mon stuff
kid you're going to be on this team
forever Sports your favorite thing I
know I want to hear
this guy is the real deal folks we're
going to see him around for a lot of
years the fans are putting the pressure
on this team just aim it at something
loud home stretch they're Rising n too
messy flash get ready to be tackled yeah
hey oh flash that's awesome the foot was
a nice defensive play and we're going to
wind up back at the plate with two outs
and he see a flash nice come on did he
not hear it this is what criminals do am
I a criminal now wearing something in
his ear I don't know presentation to my
mom she thought it was really great she
had one critique though the name she
said we should rename it heal the world
holy cow that's oh reminds me of like
those research centers once we get to
the top of the stairs your Locker's
right there right get down did he see
us I don't think so split up we me back
at the gym almost looks like Tom homes a
little bit a lot more we're in trouble
Mayday still getting a grip on it it's
cool we didn't do the origins and we're
still not doing the origins but we're at
least doing the early days yeah for sure
cuz I mean when we started he was like 8
years into being Spider-Man in the first
game where are you you little
punk someone in here playing tricks
[Music]
huh I could really use a refill on my
web shooters wait I think I have extra
web fluid stuff in the photo
lab this is all still kind of new I got
to get better it's going to be so much
fun like just these little tasks in the
early days of doing it
I know I put these under here
somewhere
gotcha damn he did all that sneaking
around got right smart place to hide it
then nobody hides stuff under there
except for gum keep moving keep
moving
okay now mix this up just right I wonder
how this stuff is going to tie back
around in the grand scheme of
[Music]
things hello
friend must be tough having to be Peter
in high school he has to always wear
long sleeves now to meet Harry at the
gym you're right though y l just did
such a good job of sounding so much
younger sorry for the mess Rick okay now
you can't tell me we don't have a damn
ghost they're looking a little out there
just a
[Music]
spider dude I thought you got caught we
got to grab that thund drod and get out
of here let's cut through the
gym It's All Coming Back
that was crazy this place looks the same
except no security guard on her Tails a
lot about like remembering your past
gives us what Hoops you sure you're up
for this question is are you let's see
it big
talker a little rusty no biggie really
show him
up that's that's
awesome like we're playing NBA 2K now I
am so happy you're feeling better
seriously thanks hey I didn't get a
chance to see what you did with Ma's
house nothing
yet I've been busy and I don't know
feels weird to change it I man you both
are terrible at basketball that must
have been really tough you're just doing
it on purpose but yeah no rush okay here
we go is he no it's the player doing
it yes well when NJ moves in maybe
she'll help with the house wow I don't
know's not even acknowledging that that
was a swish I don't know she'll move in
it's e
oh she did too I mean it seemed like you
guys were doing
good she was at your
house we'll figure it out we always do
eventually wonder how many side missions
you get of just playing basketball we're
not done
yet I know that that look yeah what is
the intention of being still think you
can find your old
Locker where do you think that security
guard is probably still in the eastest
this flashback feels like something dark
happen Locker get out of
here is it just cuz it's dark outside or
did something dark actually
happen what is this how did you go on
take it they going to do a business
together they oh crap who's that nice
touch is uh this guy part of all this
too
nope oh damn
hey dude we're going to get arrested not
if he doesn't catch
us this is not the kind of nostalgia I
like
you still got that thumb drive
yeah just got to make it to those doors
almost there open up it's the police oh
damn I call the C you're in trouble now
go but hold them off for just a minute I
got an idea what should I do don't get
caught good advice that's a good friend
right there
oh no the thumb
drive oh damn police let's
go that was the whole point of getting
in there hey you the one who called us
yeah they're in here somewhere all right
you two spread out well they got this
guy's
statement now to get the guard alone so
I can get the thumb drive back they're
in here here somewhere the guys are
looking we need your statement
where's well uh rightfield Rick I what
was
that pck it out what have you actually
seen
well sometimes these things pop for no
reason nice now I just have to distract
this last
guy
I love watching him play yeah for the
most part going get job is he trying to
hit the
balloon don't move I'll be right back
there we go figured out what he needed
to
hit he's Alone Now for Something I like
to call the upside down pickpocket
something I just invented these kids
playing tricks like I got time for this
nonsense I how he said he he needs to
figure out how to have more web fluid he
just wasted so much popcorn that tea I
like that should put me right above him
some hormonal troublemakers around in
circles like a crazy
person even got
it very nice how am I supposed to get
out of
here har I mean you figured out all that
I'm sure you can figure this
out I'm feel damn it
the Rick
[Music]
Roll that's
awesome I never thought I'd see a Rick
Roll in a video
game
good it is building their is building
their the bonding that they have yeah I
know we're getting to see the history
between them for sure it's not the cops
his
father it's my dad what does he have a
low Jack on him
you recognize the actor that plays
Norman by the way Mark Rolston he was in
Aliens RoboCop 2 and rush rush hour but
he was Drake and Aliens the one who's
obsessed with
Basquez oh no his
mother would you excuse us for moment
damn oh no
this is an important time in his
past well you called something dark yeah
I felt like it now we know why this is
so important to
[Music]
Harry he shows up in a helicopter to
tell
him rich people going to do rich
things Harry what is
this you know I still think we would
have won state if we'd
presented lot's happened in the last 10
years it's a miracle I'm even sitting
here
now I got a second chance and I'm going
to take advantage of that yeah you are
but I need you with me
Pete wow this this is uh a lot to
process why don't you come by the lab
tomorrow check it out you have a lab
already I'll show you some of my ideas
and we can talk about it some more in
the uh
deal sure in the first game when Norman
confiscated all of Oto octavius's stuff
he told Peter we going to heal the world
that uh when uh Harry comes back from
Europe you and him can start that
business you guys always talked about
maybe now it's all wrapping up yeah
that's
nice is this Craven coming to New
York silver saval back I don't know
we'll
see you are confirmed I think it's I
think it's Craven or it's the Predator
one of the crav people the Mana and
Arena are nearly complete Mr
negative on the screen s man eluded us
but Mr negative in
prison
[Music]
then he was not the
one copy that awaiting ORD
sir prepare for the transfer the way is
holding that knife it's so intimidating
fail
again
so
damn dude the cinematography is
fantastic they look like drones they
don't look like whatever those flight
transport
things not helicopters my name it's
upside down yeah
Morales and even I'm bored
[Music]
already what a way to waste your web
flu I love last game he figured out how
to do coffee upside
down
hey miles you busy I need whatever it is
I'm down need some help with a
babysitting Mission at the r sounds fun
fill me in on the
[Music]
way oh he's not really interested in his
studies is
[Music]
he stop leaving this in the
bathroom a
don't give me that look boss I'm only
taking a
break some break how's the essay going
this is very interesting going uh going
to head out though Pete call for us some
backup we're just it's better if I don't
know the details I'll be fine
Ma um you know how there have been a few
nights recently where you've been
working late and so I also worked
late well I wasn't working you're on a
date don't give me that look I'm not in
any trouble you were on a
date it's just um I've been going on
some dates dating actually oh right oh
so you're just an over Dad hi I've seen
him a few times and it's well it's going
well random person or you think it's a
super villain now what are you asking me
I'd like to have him over for
forone that's a b I'm sure there's some
spider stuff I can be doing I can give
you some going to say no this is an
interesting situation because he's
Spiderman so but if you're not
comfortable I totally understand
M look you had me at
pone you better really trust this guy
because this is quite a I mean you're
not going to obviously tell him that
your son's Spider-Man obviously but like
she is being understanding about it no
no of course but also it's not just that
your you need your son understanding
it's you're going to have to come up
with lies too when your son is not
around and has to bail out quickly so
that's
true it's an interesting
[Music]
situation